my first guest here from my house is the
Democratic mayor of Los Angeles and boy
am I glad we have one of those please
welcome Mayor Eric Garcetti they're
clapping at home I'm sure for you mr.
mayor thank you so much for being here
with me today or remotely with me here
today I wanted to have you on the show
for a long time I wish it could have
been under happier circumstances but I
guess the good news for Los Angeles is
you were the one of one of the first to
give a stay at home order and that seems
to have worked I guess my first question
is because we were first doing that
might we be one of the first to end it
well I've said the more quickly people
do things the shorter this will last and
the slower that they do things the
longer it will last so it could be but
we also were not as far into the
infection as other parts of the country
like on the East Coast so it remains to
be seen we're about 14 to 17 days kind
of behind our calendar of where New York
is we implemented these things earlier
so I'm hoping that throughout California
the first state to do this that we will
be able to get back to work and back out
of the cave as it were sooner but we're
gonna wait for public health
professionals to tell us and it we
should expect it to be a couple months
and and as our civic vice principal on
this what sort of grade would you give
Angelenos for following the order I
would say it's a solid B right now we
got an a actually in one of these groups
that grades how much our cell phones
move so if people are sneaking out there
at least keeping their cell phones at
home because it showed that we had been
the county moving the least here in
Southern California and throughout the
country but you know we see slippage of
that and I think that there's always
folks that are looking to get to the
beach we had to close that down get out
to the trails and I understand it these
are their iconic locations and places we
love to be but this really is about that
discipline of a couple weeks and
reminding people when you move you could
kill yourself and you could certainly
kill somebody else so unless it's
necessary unless you're a critical
worker stay at home
well the last I read there was 8,000
cases in a state of 40 million people
now obviously that's going to go up
because we're entering that phase now
where those numbers are going to rise
how are we doing with hospitals masks
ventilators equipment well you know we
are about 11 days behind New York City
in terms of fatalities per capita in LA
County maybe 14 days behind number of
cases but they've had more tests there
we're doing okay we're holding steady
and I hope that our state orders gives
us an extra week or two that other
places wouldn't have but every city has
to be prepared for when the cases are
gonna hit your capacity and just to put
it in perspective we have you know about
twenty-two thousand beds total in all of
our hospitals that are our general
emergency room hospitals and of those
were having only about thirteen or
fourteen 1500 of them available right
now only a couple hundred ICU beds so
these hospitals are already about 90
percent filled 95 percent filled before
the onslaught now they're building
capacity they're moving beds around
they're changing rooms that didn't have
ventilators we've got about a little bit
under a thousand ventilators unused
right now prepared for when folks come
but we're gonna hit that that that wall
whether it's in two weeks or three weeks
we are you know confident every city
will go through that we're just trying
to do our best to save as many lives as
possible do we have enough masks I know
that there has been conflicting
information even from the CDC about how
effective they are they have sometimes
made us feel like they're not that
effective I think it's got to be
somewhat more effective than nothing and
I've heard other people I think yourself
say even if it's a bandana which worries
me in LA cuz if I wear the Redwood and
then I'm out where the Crips or the
Bloods oh we're really screwed
yeah I mean look these things like this
which are different than masks I mean
they're what we call mask but they're
not medical grade masks we have about
five million of these that clothe
companies here in Los Angeles
have already started to make that they
think they can make about five million
the metaphor is like that you know
football player might be smaller than
the door
that's the virus and the door is the
size of the pores in this but if you
have five or six football players trying
to rush through at the same time it
actually can help droplets not spread
and save our grocery clerks save folks
that are doing our critical work so I'm
a big believer in them I keep waiting
for national guidance we might hear it
very soon I would just heard before
coming in here maybe the president by
the time this gets as shown we'll have
said it as well and those countries like
Czech Republic and Korea and other
places Taiwan that have them have shown
a slower rate of growth so it's
important though to remember that's
different than the surgical and the
medical grade mass that we need there
aren't enough of those we're still
holding on we've got sometimes a week or
so of supplies I've deputized the head
of our port of Los Angeles which is the
biggest port anywhere in the Americas to
be our chief logistics officer and so
we're looking at supply chains and
companies and chasing down every lead to
order for our hospital so hospitals
don't have to compete with each other
cities don't have to compete with each
other states don't have to compete with
the federal government it's a mess out
there but you know right now we're
holding on but it's week to week is the
honest answer you mentioned the
president imagine it as a Hobson's
choice as an elected official especially
in California not his favorite state
because as you know he would have won
the popular vote if not for all the
illegal voters here but it's a tough
choice for a guy like you because on the
one hand you want to tell the truth on
the other hand if you say anything
critical this president has shown that
he will deny essential services and
equipment to states that aren't nice
enough to him so I guess what I'm asking
you was how are your praising skills
when you need them for this president
well first of all bill I think you're
doing a great job
Arnon good but seriously you know I'll
say thanks to anybody that I work with
the president before this happened I was
working with Ben Carson his Secretary of
Housing and Urban Development even
though some of my Democratic friends
said don't
it comes to homelessness because he had
a genuine heart about it he was willing
to listen and we've been working
together same thing with this president
when he came to the u.s. naval ship
mercy he brought it I said thank you I
talked to folks in the White House just
days before part of what I hope helped
bring it here but I also won't be shy
about criticizing what we don't have at
the national level we don't have the
preparation for this we need to prepare
for the second spike of this when it
comes in the late fall or the early
winter we've got to use all the
resources of the federal government
better and I'm a big Federalist I love
that here in California we have states
rights we can go our own way whether
it's on immigration the environment
other things but federalism depends on
the central government doing some of the
most important things like defending our
country with Wars foreign policy
international trade and certainly a
pandemic response would fit into that
I'd like to see much more assertive
leadership much more national standards
much earlier adoption I'm glad he's now
saying that the whole country should do
this but I got on a phone call with
about 300 fellow mayors two weeks ago
just after we had done this and I said
do it now I don't care if you don't have
one single case it's coming and the way
the media reported this is there was
kind of coastal that allowed it to
become a democratic or blue state thing
you know just a week and a half ago I
was looking Wyoming had the same
infection rate as LA so did North Dakota
you know it was just per capita people
weren't looking at it they were looking
at absolute numbers so this is coming to
your town no matter what and we need
national leadership on procurement on
testing on standards and on advice well
I think you did a good job on this so
far I wish you continued luck and all of
us good luck and hopefully we won't have
here in California we are the land of
the sequel's hopefully we won't have to
be doing this again thank you so much
mr. mayor strengthen love all the core
to coming on after yes we will see you
in person soon I hope thank you sir
Cindy take care
you